Governor Ron DeSantis has officially
entered the 2024 GOP Presidential race
the announcement was by most measures a
success it garnered lots of attention it
raised a bunch of money and even the
tech glitches can be spun in a positive
way the announcement broke the internet
sort of thing uh we'll get to all of
that first though I want to get to
Trump's response which was to post a
parody video of Ron DeSantis hanging out
with George Soros Klaus Schwab the FBI
Adolf Hitler and the Devil Himself
hi everyone Welcome to our Rhonda
Sanders Twitter space hello this is my
microphone working correctly decent
waiting AI voices did you hear me we can
all hear you George can you just hold on
for a second Elon the host Dick Cheney
so how are we going to take out Trump
you guys uh
guys from the FBI this is not a private
call this is a public Twitter space
everyone can listen in
damn it everyone just be a hell up so I
can make my announcement okay you go
girl wait the devil is gay so what
everyone in this call is gay okay
it goes on from there I think you
generally get the idea
I do not know if the 2024 primary is
going to be the nastiest in history as
some people have suggested but I am
pleased to report
that it is currently on track to be the
funniest I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by my friends over at
good ranchers get great meat at a secure
price and save 20 off site-wide with my
code Knowles go to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles Canada w-l-e-s today
Rosie O'Donnell of all people speaking
of trump politics Rosie O'Donnell of all
people has become a voice of reason on
the issue of transgenderism we'll get to
that a little bit first though I want to
want to touch a little bit more on this
DeSantis announcement DeSantis did it in
this call this Twitter spaces with Elon
Musk and there were some tech glitches
and it was a little bit flat you know if
I had to be critical of the announcement
I would say there wasn't a ton of energy
it obviously just lacked the enthusiasm
that a live event could generate that
said it's not a total knock on DeSantis
president Trump's announcement for his
2024 campaign also was kind of flat Tim
Scott's recent announcement the
microphone broke I'm not convinced that
presidential campaign announcements
really matter at all do you remember any
of them I vaguely remember Obama's
I Reagan 1980 I kind of remember
at the Statue of Liberty
nobody really remembers these things it
doesn't really matter the question is
can they go the distance there was a
deeply
perhaps pregnant meaningful moment
during the Twitter spaces where as
people poured in and it started to
glitch a little bit the the screen said
preparing to launch and that's the
question Rhonda Santos has been
preparing to launch his campaign for a
very long time now for years everyone
has known that he's going to run for
president there's been a lot of hype
there's been hype from conservatives
there's been hype from
establishmentarians there's been hype
from anti-trumpers there's even been
hype from people who are pro-trump or
who were pro-trump but don't think he
can win in 2024. so there's a lot of
hype there's a lot of expectations from
a lot of different people and some of
those expectations are going to be
contradictory so we've seen a lot of
preparation to launch now what matters
is how does the campaign do now that it
is out in the open
can DeSantis withstand the Trump meat
grinder Donald Trump seemed like a pig
just rolling around in the happiest most
wonderful mud and muck this is a family
show so I'll clean up the language that
you could imagine yesterday as DeSantis
is doing the launch he's just cracking
jokes and he's posting videos of Klaus
Schwab and Hitler and the devil and he
is
posting all sorts of little truth social
one-liners one of them
was quote Tim Scott's presidential
launch even with the broken microphone
don't pay the contractor Tim was by far
the best presidential launch of the week
robs was a catastrophe
and there's a lot just from a pure
comedy composition perspective there is
so much there so he says oh yeah Tim
Scott's was the best of the week first
of all Tim Scott's presidential
announcement was obviously the only
other one of the week he starts
mentioning that Tim Scott's microphone
cut out and then gives him advice not to
pay his campaign contractor but then the
funniest part is he refers to Ron
DeSantis someone who everyone knows we
all know what his name is as Rob and
this is a tactic that is used by men
when they're trying to pick up a girl
and maybe that girl has a boyfriend and
maybe that girl is seeing somebody and
you go up and say oh yeah hey Sheila
yeah oh man looking nice today yeah we
should uh we should get a drink sometime
hey how's Mark doing
and Sheila
will hear this and say oh actually you
know my boyfriend's name is Matt
and you you say oh yeah whatever and
then you move on right it's a way to
belittle somebody and to disrespect
somebody and Trump is doing it in this
extremely officious way yeah Rob
DeSantis and there's a play on words
because he's going to accuse DeSantis of
robbing the nomination or trying to rob
the nomination from Trump or robbing his
mannerisms or personality or something
like that so
disados's announcement came off pretty
much as expected Trump's reaction
certainly came off as expected what do
we make of that all in all it's pretty
good for DeSantis there's one weak spot
right now which is on foreign policy
DeSantis after the Twitter space went on
Trey Gowdy's show on Fox News and
DeSantis explained
what his views are vis-a-vis Ukraine or
maybe he didn't quite explain those
views you uh wore the uniform if you are
elected president you may be the first
one in a while uh to have worn the
uniform how would you address the
ongoing war in Eastern Europe between
Russia and Ukraine on day one of a
Rhonda Sanchez presidency well first I
think what we need to do as a veteran is
recognize that our military has become
politicized you talk about gender
ideology you talk about things like
global warming that they're somehow
concerned and that's not the military
that I served in we need to return our
military to focusing on commitment
focusing on the core values and the core
mission that would be something that I
could take care of on day one there'll
be a new sheriff in town as
commander-in-chief and I think you'll
see recruiting start to get back to
where it needs to be because people
don't want to join awoke military and I
think it's been really really
problematic look in terms of what's
going on over in Eastern Europe you know
I'd like to see a settlement of this I
do not want to see a wider War I think
it's completely unknowable what it will
look like in January of 2025 but I would
not want to see the United States with
our troops uh get a messed in a war in
Russia or in Ukraine
it's a hard question on a hard topic
that most voters don't generally
base their presidential decisions on
most voters are basing their decisions
on domestic policy and so Governor
DeSantis here is trying to Pivot the
question from this thorny issue of
Ukraine which splits the GOP onto this
issue of wokeness in the military but
wokeness in the military obviously has
nothing to do with the policy of the
president vis-a-vis Russia and Ukraine
and this war that's now been expanding
for over a year a war that's really been
expanding for more like
eight or nine years at this point uh
I I think DeSantis has to get a clearer
answer on this this issue if the war
continues on the trajectory that it's on
this could come to to play a large role
in the presidential campaign and so he's
going to need I think clearer views here
Trump whether you love him or you hate
him has relatively clear views on these
things and they upset a lot of subtle
GOP Orthodoxy DeSantis has done a very
very good job in the State of Florida
but as any Governor has ever run for
president knows deep down these
individual states don't have a foreign
policy
so I think he's got a he's got to come
up with an answer there and uh well he
says I don't want a wider War I want to
come to a settlement that that's good
that's the right direction but the
question is how are you going to do that
what are these specific issues that you
are going to focus on and and
furthermore even to the way he answered
the question can he be agile can he be
dexterous
can he when he doesn't want to answer a
question can he pivot in a way that's a
little more subtle can he turn the
question to something he does want to
answer can he throw in a joke can he
throw in a Barb can he be fast on his
feet whatever you want to say about
Trump whether you love him or you hate
him the guy is one of the best showmen
of our age the guy knows how to command
a stage and to command a camera DeSantis
just doesn't come from that background
he's had a very different life and so if
he's going to take Trump on that's going
to have to be something that he works on
Ron DeSantis could have the absolute
best policy of any governor in the
history of the United States but he's
now going to have to go Toe to Toe with
a very persuasive funny
Showbiz guy and and so that's going to
have to be the area that he and his team
really focus on one way
to perform better and better every
single day is to make sure you eat a
good strong dinner you get that iron
pumping through your body that's why you
got to check out
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
Memorial Day is a time to honor and
remember our brave service men and women
who made the ultimate sacrifice for our
country it is also a time to come
together as a nation gather with loved
ones and enjoy some mouth-watering meals
what better way to do that than with
premium 100 American meat from good
ranchers good ranchers is not like the
other meat delivery companies that
import a majority of their products they
are passionate about delivering the
finest 100 American meat right to your
doorstep
here's something special good ranchers
proudly offers a 10 discount to all past
and present service members as a way of
saying thank you for their service but
that's not it
in honor of Memorial Day good ranchers
is giving our listeners an exclusive
opportunity when you use code Knowles
Canada wles you can save 20 off
site-wide from tender steaks to
succulent chicken goodranchors.com has
it all I had the other night a juicy
delicious good ranchers burger and it's
it's the best
it's the best burger out there and the
steaks are just Juicy and Delicious and
it's just top shelf meat okay fire up
the grill on Memorial Day and your
family and friends will thank you for it
they will know that the meat that
everyone is enjoying is not only of the
highest quality but also supports
American ranchers goodranches.com head
on over use code Knolls save 20 site
wide the more you stock up on the more
you will save during the Memorial Day
sale promo code knows at
goodranchers.com good ranchers American
Meat delivered
speaking of dodging questions green
Jean-Pierre White House Press actually
was asked a question about the sisters
of Perpetual Indulgence which is this
rapidly anti-christian particularly
anti-catholic drag queen Troop that is
being honored by the LA Dodgers more
like el gay Dodgers if you ask me
tip your waitress she was asked this
question because the president is at
least nominally Catholic here's her
answer
this is one that's really caught the eye
of a lot of uh Catholics and Christians
and it's in frankly they're they're hurt
by this the the LA Dodgers are honoring
a group called The Sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence during a pride night game
next month the Archdiocese of La
Catholic leaders there say the group
mocks the Catholic faith and women
religious who serve the poor and sick
and is asking all Catholics to stand
against bigotry and hate in any form the
president is Catholic we all know what
is this reaction to this story look I
appreciate the question Owen I'm just
not going to get into the middle of uh
of of uh who a sports team is going to
honor or should honor or should not
honor that's just not something that I'm
going to get in the middle of it has
made it a you know very very important
in religious freedom he's issue
statements in the past saying all people
of all religion should be treated with
equal dignity and respect I know I know
you you know what you said you just said
there you kind of want to stay out of it
but isn't this a prime example of
something like that I'm just not going
to get in the middle of who a sports
team decides to honor or not honor that
is not just not going to get in the
middle of that but appreciate the
question oh yeah I'm not going to get in
the middle of that we listen we
from political office we're not going to
get involved with what sports teams are
doing right as if the entire Democratic
party didn't weigh in on the NFL
kneeling
a white supremacy Fiasco of 2016-2017 as
if Joe Biden could he ever keep his
mouth shut on any of these cultural
issues as if the White House didn't
invite Dylan Mulvaney
to come do an interview with him give me
a break what are you talking about
White House is always involved in these
things he just doesn't want to comment
on this because it's indefensible and
yet he knows that his side is on the
side of the anti-christian
drag queens
and so he he doesn't want to put himself
in a bad position where he's going to
have to overtly and publicly disavow his
faith in order to decide with them
but he also doesn't want to defend the
faith
because he knows where his bread is
buttered at least in this world it's
it's with the anti-christians
so so they keep their mouths shut okay
it is increasingly clear that we are
facing an assault on Christianity and on
all traditional views of society and
morality and religion even for people
who don't consider themselves Christian
you probably cherish a lot of the fruits
of Christian civilization and now all of
that is under assault so when you ask me
which candidate do I want to back in
2024 is it Trump is it DeSantis is it
Chris Christie don't count Chris
Christian is it Vivek ramaswamy is it
Nikki is it this is it
I
want to back the candidate
that can see the assault on religion
that is going on right now the sacrilege
that is going on right now that will not
merely
chip away at popular piety but will
fundamentally undermine all of the most
important aspects of our society
because religion is not just some fun
little hobby that people have in society
or they don't religion is what animates
the whole society and so if you live in
a culture that publicly mocks religion
then you're you're not going to have a
very flourishing Society so which
candidate am I going to go for I'd like
the candidate who can credibly
propose to stop that all-out assault the
ridiculous line from the White House oh
it's just some little sports team thing
right Sports is public this is the team
of the city the LA Dodgers public Sports
have always had a patriotic component
they tell us a lot about what our
culture believes what our political
order is going to be of course we've got
to be involved If Sports weren't
political the LA Dodgers wouldn't be
honoring a sac-religious drag Troop of
course it's political and you're going
to keep your mouth shut because the
politics is going in your direction and
you don't want to upset that I want a
Republican presidential candidate who's
willing to upset that some Republicans
are doing this sort of thing in Montana
they just banned drag queen Story Hour
one of the biggest fights on the right
among movement conservatives and
conservative intellectuals and the
activist class not necessarily the rank
and file card-carrying Republican voter
but the people who are setting the
agenda for what the party believes one
of the biggest fights six seven years
ago was over drag queen Story Hour and
you had the Liberal Republicans like
David French who's now just become a
liberal now he's an economist for the
New York Times David French said drag
queen Story Hour is a Blessing of
Liberty our constitution gives us that
beautiful right to jiggle around in
stilettos for kids in the library or
whatever and then you had the
conservative conservatives who came out
and said no there's no right to drag
queen Story Hour if James Madison ever
thought this were in the Constitution
he'd be rolling over in his grave that's
obviously not real and and that was a
big battle
well if we have freedom of speech we
need to have weirdo guys jiggling around
for children
um no that's actually not what freedom
of speech is freedom of speech involves
all sorts of limits and taboos and
standards and we're not going to do that
okay well Montana is saying the
conservatives won we're going to ban
drag queen Story Hour uh Governor Greg
John Forte signed HB 359
over half the state ledge co-sponsored
the bill it bars miners from attending
sexually oriented shows says a school or
library that receives any form of
funding from the state may not
allow a sexually oriented performance or
drag Story Hour on its premises during
regular operating hours or at any school
sanctioned extracurricular activity goes
on there can be uh punishments obviously
against the people who violate this and
then the legislator behind the law came
out and was totally clear even if the
law weren't totally clear and it's it's
pretty precise he says there is no such
thing as a family friendly drag show
which is of course true and everybody
knew that until a few years ago you want
to go see a drag show go into this seedy
part of town with the red lights and the
dodgy characters go to Greenwich Village
or something if you're in New York but
don't go to Coney Island but don't
you're not going to do that at an
elementary school and you're not going
to do that at a library that's great
news keep it up Montana some Republicans
are squishing on this though an even
more urgent issues than the drag Story
Hour Louisiana
the home state of my maternal
grandfather I've got some Louisiana in
me I'm very sad to say one of my family
heritage States
just blocked a bill to Outlaw transiting
the kids and it wasn't a Democrat who
blocked the bill it was a Republican
this Republican state senator Fred Mills
just joined Democrats in a 5-4 vote so
it's the decisive vote
on the Health and Welfare committee to
block the advancement of a bill that
would have been that would have banned
using cross-sex hormones puberty
blockers and surgery to alter a Minor's
appearance in an attempt to validate a
Minor's perception of his sex if the
miner's perception is inconsistent with
his sex with Republicans like Fred Mills
who needs Democrats I know that Fred
mills's office
his his phone number is available online
on the Louisiana state government
website I I would strongly encourage
concerned louisianans and and Senator
mills's constituents to call his office
and express your view and of course a
polite and just way that it is
unacceptable to defend tranzing the kids
what kind of
[Music]
strong
the answer to that question would
probably be a Democrat or a liberal but
in this case Fred Mills is a Republican
and with Republicans like this truly
there is no need for Democrats this
Republican primary is going to be a
clarifying experience that's why I'm
generally pro-primary is because it
forces candidates to take clearer
positions on these sorts of issues and
some issues we can be be a little
conciliatory on some issues have to be
very very clear any Republican that
defends
tranzing the kids
is a far left radical liberal
and should be given No Quarter should
not receive a single Republican vote
ever should not receive a single penny
from any conservative and his government
office should receive lots of phone
calls from concerned constituents now
if you're if you're maybe in this
this extremely confused State senator's
District you're probably going to want
to move out of town you know you're
probably going to want to go to a
district with decent political
leadership when you want to move
anywhere
when you want to just get in your car go
for a ride you got to check out carzane
right now go to carzing.com Knowles
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for everyone especially if
you're a first time buyer or if you have
no credit before you walk into a
dealership and spend the whole day with
the crowds and the stress and the
potential that you won't even find the
right car you got to check out carzing
carzing is completely changing the way
that you buy a car online by partnering
with Credit Agencies lenders and over 25
000 dealers Nationwide cars and provides
you with everything you need before
stepping foot into a dealership you can
instantly pre-qualify online without
affecting your credit score get instant
financing details including what your
down payment would be your monthly
payment term and APR putting you several
steps ahead of other buyers once you
find the right car at your ideal budget
all you have to do is bring your saved
deal voucher with you to the dealership
to finalize your next ride super simple
even if you're not in the market for a
new car check out cars in anyway browse
your dream cars see what they have to
offer for when you are ready to buy
carzing helps make your experience
faster cheaper and less stressful go to
carzing.com Knowles today skip the
guesswork and find the best deals for
you carzing.com Knowles
seems as if fewer and fewer of us are on
the same page when it comes to the
fundamentals these days and this is
obviously a huge problem when it comes
to our relationship to each other and
our relationship to God it's not a new
phenomenon the consequences of this
disunity date all the way back to the
time of Moses just listen to what Jordan
Peterson has to say about it in Exodus
there's an irony here that
for all the insistence upon
equality
the very foundation for that equality in
Western culture i the idea that human
beings are made in the Imago day in the
image of God has been lost of course so
it's almost as if because of the erosion
of this Foundation
the drive for equality is stressed all
the more that's that's exactly what
needs you that's exactly what Nietzsche
claimed would happen when he wrote well
when he's particularly in Beyond Good
and Evil he said that was that was
inevitable that would be an inevitable
consequence Jordan is joined by a round
table of big thinkers from different
backgrounds who explore one of the most
important books in the Bible it is
engrossing all episodes of Exodus are
now available exclusively for daily wire
Plus members if you have not seen it
start at the beginning because it's well
worth your time dailywire.com subscribe
to watch Exodus
we are winning on the trans issue and so
any Republican who goes squishy not only
has zero backbone and maybe is missing
some other anatomical features as far as
I'm concerned but also just has no idea
what time it is does not does not have
any clear perception of where politics
is in this country
look at what's going on at Target
look at the Target CEO
had recently come out to defend the
pride month displays which include
bathing suits meant for tucking women's
bathing suits meant for men so that they
could tuck the features that are male so
they could look more like women even
though there are bathing suits already
that are fine for men to talk they're
called men's bathing suits
Target CEO defends the
lgbtq plus friendly displays for little
kids even
and he says that these products are not
only good for business they're the right
thing for society
the right thing for society
Target CEO Brian Cornell
okay
Target needs the Bud Light treatment
nobody expected that this Bud Light
boycott would be as successful as it is
Bud Light has lost more than 15 billion
dollars in market cap this has been
going on for so much longer than anybody
thought it would no one expected it
Target needs that too
sometimes it's very difficult to launch
a boycott
certain companies really have dominance
and it's hard to do it but but other
companies even when they have the
premier product in the category Bud
Light was the most popular beer in
America
other companies are susceptible to
boycotting Bud Light obviously was
Target obviously is there are other
options to Target there's Walmart there
is Costco I assume Jeremy's going to
have his own gigantic Superstore pretty
soon too come visit Jeremy's 20
000 foot retail shop
there are options it's too bad I like
Target well enough
I don't love it but they've got a decent
selection of Spindrift I'm a millennial
I like flavored Seltzer okay I'm gonna
have to give that up that's a sacrifice
that I'm going to have to make
in other Generations people have been
asked to make sacrifices like get on a
ship and go over to Normandy and be
strafed on the beach okay we're being
asked to make the sacrifice of hey maybe
drive a little bit further across town
hey maybe you're gonna have to pick up
your cup of coffee before you get into
the shop instead of in the shop like
target has the little coffee shops hey
maybe you're gonna have to trade out
your Target card for a Walmart card okay
Target is doubling down
on pushing kids into radical sexual
ideologies and transiting people can't
let them get away with that
if
Target right now is is actually
following the Bud Light Playbook almost
to a t which is they're doubling down on
the radical sex ideology
then they're kind of backing away a
little bit but then they're doubling
down again they need that BL treatment
baby we got to think bigger we've got to
expand our imagination one of the
Republicans who's doing this right now
Jim Banks Jim Banks is doing a
phenomenal job
because Jim Banks wants to enshrine
maybe my favorite executive order from
president Trump and that would be the
make Federal buildings beautiful again
executive order
they're going to be some people
some utilitarian economists officers and
calculators out there who look at this
they say with all the problems we have
in this country you're going to focus on
making buildings beautiful again yes
we got immigration problems we got
abortion we got Trans in the kids we got
World War III you're going to focus on
making buildings beautiful
yes you have to
conservatives are pretty good at talking
about the difference between true and
false conservatives are getting better
at talking about the difference between
good and evil we got to move on to that
third transcendental Beauty we need to
be able to identify the difference
between Beauty and ugliness a
civilization that has beautiful
buildings that is in a beautiful place
is going to have higher Spirits it's
going to see the truth more clearly it's
going to behave in a more civilized way
it's going to be a better Civilization
by almost any measure
a civilization that lives like rats
that's going to be a civilization that's
going to behave like rats okay
sometimes the ugly buildings are a
symptom of a corrupted culture but also
those ugly buildings will further
corrupt the culture you can't neatly
separate those things
sometimes people say politics is
Downstream of culture you could also say
culture is Downstream politics you can't
neatly separate these things okay
and this fight
this beautifying Federal Civic
architecture Act
if signed into law
would mandate the quote classical
architecture and the historic humanistic
architecture including Gothic Romanesque
Pueblo Revival Spanish Colonial and
other Mediterranean styles of
architecture historically rooted in
various regions of America be preferred
for new federal office design so this is
a better law even than the Trump
executive order in that it's more
specific on which kinds of architectural
styles are appropriate for different
parts of the country and that different
geographies in which they're situated
it's a little more more precise
this is great and the other reason that
this is really important is that this
kind of a law is going to highlight a
major split on the right and it's not
only going to highlight that split on
the right because you've got some of the
Republicans who are the just the
business Republicans just the money
Republicans they're the Republicans who
there are so officers economists and
calculators to quote Edmund Burke
they're the ones who don't really pay
attention to the deeper things in life
they just they just want to make some
money and then you've got the cultural
conservatives the social conservatives
the traditional conservatives who
realize that life is about more than
money
but it even gets down to the question of
what kind of architecture do we want
this is this gets to a fundamental split
on the right because it's the plot of
The Fountainhead by Iron Rand the plot
of the fountain had by Iron Rand is that
the bad guys want there to be classical
beautiful architecture in the city
and the ostensible hero of the story
Howard Roark wants ugly modernist
architecture
and oddly enough some conservatives at
least in the 1980s really like Dian Rand
they were very pro-ine Rand even though
Ein Rand is a modernist materialist
atheist writer because she didn't like
the Communists the right embraced her to
some degree
that's going to be a split what do we
want there was always schizophrenia for
the past 30 years there's been
schizophrenia on the right at Republican
fundraisers which is the first part of
the speech would say we need to preserve
Traditional Values we need to preserve
the historic American Nation we need to
conserve the family we need to build up
those institutions that have served us
well for hundreds of years
and we need creative destruction we need
to tear everything down we need to
innovate we need modernity we need the
future we need we need to tear up the
past forget that old stupid pest we're
gonna build gigantic skyscrapers and
rocket ships okay
there's a little contradiction there
not saying we need to freeze ourselves
in Amber that's not possible but
as we move inevitably into the future
are we going to do so by preserving what
is best in our civilization but are we
going to do so with humility
are we going to do so with caution
slowing down a little bit Evolution not
Revolution or are we going to adopt the
perspective that is essentially the
perspective of the Liberals and say ah
yeah that old stuff that's dumb that's
bad who needs all that forget we're in
the New Age steal glass big giant flat
modernist buildings that's what we want
which is it there has been a split on
the right and Jim Banks is right and
Iran is wrong and that we should totally
defend Beauty because there are Eternal
principles of beauty Ein rand's argument
in The Fountainhead is that
circumstances are the chief determinants
of what is beautiful
so Gothic architecture or classical
architecture that that won't look good
in the modern age because today we've
we're more Adept at working with steel
and metal and because we're in modernity
we've just got to build big boring ugly
skyscrapers or something like that we
just have to it's a it's a very
Progressive idea of beauty
but the conservative the traditional
idea of beauty is no that some things
are just beautiful some things are just
beautiful and some things aren't and try
as you might you can try for years and
years and years to make
mutilation and
uh minimalism and degradation you can
try to make that beautiful but it never
will be beautiful because beauty is not
merely in the eye of the beholder but
it's an objective reality that we can
perceive and that we can reason about
and we can deduce things about and we we
can know okay
very different perspectives all of that
contained in this one little Bill about
Federal buildings from Jim Banks but he
gets it and the rest of the right should
too there are good signs on this front
okay
bills like the make building is
beautiful again act these are the subtle
aspects of politics
it's not the big headline shiny lights
immigration bad cut taxes win the war
it's not like that it's a little bit
more subtle
but the way that the left has overtaken
our culture has been in a subtle way the
way that the serpent in the Garden of
Eden fooled Adam and Eve it was in a
subtle way it was the subtle creature
and that's what the libs do
conservatives are finally waking up to
that
what's probably the subtlest way
that the libs have been able to overtake
our culture by taking over education
because because for a long time
conservatives didn't really think of
Education as a political fight
I said oh you know who cares those woke
snowflakes
wait until they get into the real world
it won't matter what happened in schools
well what happened this whoa snowflakes
got into the real world they changed the
real world of course because a classroom
is like a crystal ball
and if a student is raised
from K-12 now people go to preschool and
now they go to pre-preschool so let's
say from age three through age not just
18 but then into college
which people increasingly were going to
and then maybe master's degrees and then
maybe phds
you get all that time for the libs to
form the mind and the soul of America's
youth
people are going to end up huge Libs
they're not even going to be aware of it
this is how the so-called conservatives
have ended up so liberal and adopted so
many liberal premises totally unawares
because they've just been steeped in
that like a tea bag in a in a pot of hot
water for 20 years of their lives
so there's some good news on this front
which is that college enrollment
is down
college enrollment is down again even
three years after the lockdowns that
really gave a sucker punch to college in
America
public four-year institutions saw a 0.8
percent enrollment decline as of the
spring of 2023
2022 that decline was 1.2 percent it's a
lot bigger than the decline 0.3 percent
in 2021 0.2 percent in 2020 so for years
now you're seeing a pretty steady
decline
private four-year colleges witnessed a
1.0 percent decrease in 2023 following
1.2 percent following point four percent
following point six percent so colleges
slowly maturely
decreasing this is a great thing
not everybody needs to go to college not
everybody should go to college the
insistence that everybody has to go to
the exact same kind of college and
education has led to a dramatic decline
in the standards within those colleges
such that even the students who are a
little more inclined to go to college
can't get the college education that
they previously could so it benefits
absolutely nobody
it harms society as a whole
now we're turning that around the libs
waged what what they called a Long March
through the institutions
this is a Long March through the
institutions to take over the colleges
and universities especially but also
lower education and also the nonprofit
education all the rest of it
they did that for decades and decades
and decades and they transformed
education in the United States what
conservatives can do now
is lead a long march
out
or a long march not just out we're not
just fleeing from something
we have a long march to build new
institutions there are conservative
colleges that have been built up
thinking of places like Hillsdale
thinking of places like Ave Maria
Franciscan Liberty thinking of these
Thomas Aquinas College these these
institutions that
some of which are relatively new at
least in their present iterations and
they say hey
maybe you want to go to Harvard or Yale
or Princeton but those places aren't
what they used to be
come over here you'll get a real
classical educational liberal education
properly liberal meaning to help you
make sense of your freedom come on over
here
my friend Spencer Clavin has pointed out
he says he thinks that we will get to a
point in society where wise people will
recognize a Hillsdale education as being
more impressive than a Harvard Education
and
every year since he made that prediction
it seems to be more and more true that's
what we've got to do that's what the
daily wire is about we're building a new
institution we don't need to put up with
stupid Hollywood we don't need to put up
with the corporate
establishment news media even the right
wing establishment news media are
left-wing they Embrace radical leftist
ideology they Embrace transgenderism for
goodness sakes we don't need to put up
with that
our argument is if you build it they
will come we're not beholden to Bud
Light anymore we're not beholden to
Target anymore we're not beholden to
Harvard anymore we're not beholden to
any of it that's our bet and certain
people are putting a lot of money down
on that and it seems like it is paying
off it seems like people are leaving
those old institutions where are they
going to go they're going to go
somewhere
why can't they come to the places that
we are building you know this Monday
we are releasing a new episode of yes or
no speaking of our political order it
will feature former White House Press
Secretary no not Jen saki the one and
only Sean Spicer it was great sitting
down to discuss very spicy topics with
Mr Spicer
check out this teaser
white hate is now more widely accepted
than the 2020 election results
oh this is a gimmick oh that's well done
I mean
this is an episode you are not going to
want to miss also while yes or no is fun
to watch it's even more fun to play yes
or no the game is available for
pre-order over at dailywire.com shop
you're gonna say Michael pre-order I
thought it was available to order yes it
was and I told you it was going to sell
out instantly and it did
and then it was available for pre-order
again we ordered many thousands more
copies of it and I said you got to get
it in now because it's going to sell out
and then it did so we're getting it back
we're going to order many many thousands
of more copies of it and you know what's
going to happen I bet it's gonna sell
out again so make sure you get your
pre-order in right now do not regret
missing it again dailyword.com shop
bring the fun home host your very own
spectacle of titillating topics head on
over to my YouTube channel on Monday
to wind down from your Memorial Day
festivities go to dailywire.com
shop to secure your game today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Jim libke says if God doesn't Smite
America this pride month he owes Sodom
and Gomorrah an apology and that's a
quote apparently from my pal Seamus
Coughlin yes that's a fair point
even in the days of Sodom and Gomorrah
what people are doing to children now
what people are stating about objective
reality in human nature
they weren't going that far Fair Point
from Mr Coughlin okay and on that very
topic
I didn't think I would see this day
Rosie O'Donnell
has become a voice of reason on the
gender Madness
me that her stuffed animals were
non-binary I'm like here we go
here we go and I said okay well what
does that mean she goes they don't feel
like a boy and they don't feel like a
girl I said well that's fantastic you
know what's funny is that I'm a girl who
people used to call a tomboy because I
liked all the boy stuff when I was
little and you know what's weird I still
do really like the boy stuff I like
football I like riding a motorcycle I
like to do a lot of stuff that boys
traditionally like to do but you know
what else never was confused about
thinking if I was a boy or a girl always
knew I was a girl and loved being a girl
so you can be a girl and feel any way
you want or you can figure out what it
what it is and I'm like rambling and
rambling and she said are you done are
you done
this was Rosie O'Donnell's daughter was
saying I don't know if I feel like a
girl or a boy and Rosie making this
point saying you can be a girl and still
like the boy stuff
of course had Rosie O'Donnell been a
child today
depending on her parents and her
community they almost certainly would
have tried to trans her but she says no
I'm not a boy I'm a girl
I'm a girl who has a sexual desire for
other girls I'm a girl who likes to ride
motorcycles I'm a girl who likes to
watch football but I'm a girl because
you can't change that
and even the people who think that you
can change that that if if you're a girl
but you like football you're a boy and
you need to chop your body up they know
that they're not identical with boys
even the really pro-trans people they
know that there's a difference they know
that they're in some ways at least
they're like the sex that they appear to
be and are
so Rosie's just giving a different
perspective here
and
Rosie is more right than most people on
this issue it's not even quite so simple
as Rosie is making it though
there's some people who are saying
being a girl is purely about biology
X chromosomes in a uterus and then there
are other people who are saying being a
girl has nothing to do with Biology it
has to do with whether you have pretty
dresses and Barbie dolls
and they're the first group of people
they'll say no actually it has nothing
to do with whether you like Barbie doll
you can not like Barbie dolls you can
wear blue jeans and
neither side is totally right I I was at
the TP USA Pastors conference yesterday
I'm not I am not a pastor but I was
speaking to a group of of pastors there
and a young woman came up to me
and she said Michael
what is a woman
we never seem to get an answer to that
it's a it's a great question and the
Liberals can't answer it but we we don't
really seem to get a precise answer on
the right either sometimes people will
say oh it's a an adult female okay sure
but
what does that mean and sometimes people
say X chromosomes but okay what does
that mean sometimes people will say the
Barbie dolls and the dresses and so what
is it
and one answer that I like to give is
that a woman is sugar spice and
everything nice I think that's much more
precise than any of the other answers
that people give
being a girl
is is about a lot of different things
and where Rosie goes a little bit wrong
actually is she says you can like
whatever you want do whatever you want
still be a girl well yeah maybe but
actually if you're a girl you are called
to do certain things
you actually do have certain
[Music]
a certain kind of purpose
you actually do have certain behaviors
that are implied by your biology by
yourself
and I know that's not popular to say
these days but it's true and if you're a
man you have certain obligations and
duties too and you can act like a man
a woman is not
just her body a woman is at least her
body but she's not just her body there's
more to being a woman than that so
Rosie's on the right track but there's
more to say
now
speaking as we must and as we as we will
for the next
I was going to say 30 days it's probably
going to be the next 30 Years about
transgenderism another company
has gone super duper gay not just Bud
Light not just Ford not just what was
the company what was the earlier company
today Target
even that very finest most cherished
brand of suburban white girls in the
mid-2000s North Face
has gone trans
hi it's me Patagonia a real-life
homosexual and today I'm here with the
North Face we are here to invite you to
come out
in nature with us wow this is nice we
like to call this little tour the summer
of Pride this tour has everything hiking
community art lesbians lesbians making
art last year we gave saw shade Across
the Nation and celebrated Pride Across
the Nation with hundreds of you across
the nation this year we're back back
again with two new stops Atlanta GA why
because you're there in Salt Lake City
we're coming for you
of course this year all these fabulous
speakers will be coming from inside this
TV to a nature near you so come outside
and celebrate the beautiful LG HGTV
community
[Music]
it's pretty gay
so there's no way this is real is it
this can be real
the fact that I don't know I guess tells
you a lot about where our culture is
a very highly produced ad though
and the guy who's dressed up like a girl
he has a mustache I love that last line
there gets to what we're talking about
with Jim Banks he says we got to
celebrate this beautiful commercial this
beautiful community
and this is what animates so much of the
LGBT activism
is
a an inversion of beauty
that it's it's not really about a man
dressing up like a woman and it's not
really like a woman dressing up like a
man
it's about people who have every person
has some
Beauty to them because we're made in the
image and likeness of God it's about
people taking whatever beauty that they
have in them that they could cultivate
that they could accentuate that they
could simply allow to
exist and trying to suppress that and to
distort that and to pervert that that's
what it's about
it's about highlighting the the
most grotesque images that that one
possibly can we've been talking about
porn a lot this week because I did that
interview with the uh porn expert and
this is one of the characteristics of
pornography is that it just becomes more
and more grotesque to the point that
something doesn't even appear like
pornography I had I was forced by my
producers to do a video of ASMR
which involve people like eating foods
and making disgusting sounds there's a
pornographic aspect to all that even
though it's it's so perverse that it
it's hard to even see how it in any way
could relate to sensuality but that's
what happens that's that's what happens
with grotesquery and we're we're living
in a culture that is highlighting the
grotesque that cause a urinal on a wall
or on a floor a work of art
that calls the the most
intentionally
revolting things
beautiful and and does so in order to
force us to lie and to sever our our
relationship to sever the tether that we
have to reality and to the truth to deny
that such an objective thing could exist
at all
I I've never owned a North Face I didn't
have enough money growing up in the
suburbs I was not a white girl I
remained not a white girl
tip of the iceberg
it's going to be so many Brands this
year we'll see if any of them hold back
now that they recognize that
conservatives are actually willing to
fight them on it to stop giving them
their money
pride month 2023 will be a very
important test of our political order
probably more so even than the 2024
presidential primary okay today is
trailer Thursday
is it I don't know we got to come up
with some better names Ben Davies tells
me
that the Padre Pio movie that had been
teased some months ago with Shia LaBeouf
who apparently converted to Catholicism
during the process of portraying this
character because of the traditional
Latin as well apparently the movie got
distribution the trailer is out I've not
seen it yet we'll take a look at that in
the member block the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member use code Noel scanner
wlas at checkout for two months free on
all annual plans
[Music]
thank you